il était collaborateur dans des grands
groupes ils se sont lancés dans la
création de leur entreprise neuf
entrepreneurs ont été mises à l'honneur
lors d'une soirée le 4 décembre dernier
des créateurs d'entreprises issus de
l'essaimage
le principe les grands groupes
accompagnent leurs salariés dans le
lancement de leurs activités
l'essaimage peut prendre tous les types
de créations d'entreprises hors certains
sont un peu lié à l'activité initiale du
groupe mais pas complètement sinon les
laisserait pas partir et beaucoup
peuvent être des projets de reconversion
complète des gens qui vont se former
pour se reconvertir dans un autre métier
une vingtaine d'entreprises composent
l'association diez organisatrice de cet
événement présente notamment deux
anciens salariés d'airbus à elancourt en
2013 il crée l'entreprise quotidien en
une création d'entreprise accompagnés
par airbus développement
leur spécialité le stockage d'énergie
électrique sous forme d'hydrogène
l'hydrogène c'est un vrai vecteur
énergétique et on peut le produire
soi-même en électrisant d'eau
donc quand j'ai trop d'énergie au lieu
de le perdre et puis quand mes batteries
sont pleines
j'en fais quoi je jette énergie voilà
donc là je vais électro lisais
tranquillement de l'aude je vais mettre
du gaz le gaz ou le mettez dans une
bonbonne si elle est en jeu vous revenez
vingt ans après vous avez la même
quantité d'énergie
c'est un but qui est un but sociétale on
accompagne sur les territoires où on est
implanté
le développement de l'emploi on ne peut
pas forcément faire nous mêmes c'est de
permettre à des gens de réaliser leurs
rêves qu'ils n'arrivent pas forcément
réalisés dans l'entreprise ça crée de
l'emploi
ça permet de faire du développement
technologique les neuf entreprises
lauréates de la soirée on créer 200
emplois